oh god it's another one of those parts
[Applause]
the hell are these anyway
fastest [ __ ] that's what
they're coming they keep dodging
yeah
my advice do not touch any more parts
they're all over the place
[ __ ] we got monsters snatching people
things jumping out of pods
yeah no idea what the hell's going on
but I'm not the only one
think so but there is a lot of that [ __ ]
down here can you get back up no you
guys come down but just just watch it oh
man you weren't kidding
watch your step we need to get out of
here
so these pots the incubators we're put
in and they come out we need to find my
dad and soon
great now there's doors not
easy
let's cut through the snot
take a guess with my mouth how's it
taste
how do you think it tastes bad probably
right it smells [ __ ] after it more if
those goddamn things
are we clear
thanks oh yeah
[Music]
all right now we're clear
come on this way
Wow we're gonna have to redefine our
definition up clear
you know give me a hand with this
so we follow this this snatcher thing
then what
then we find my dad Reina and everyone
else they snatched yeah okay but what if
it wants us to follow it it's making a
big mistake
hey there's a snot bubble up there
what's that inside it
Sanofi dad's radio mom she's got to be
close
that toward that translation let's go
dammed us a lot
[Applause]
watch it
so fast now
alright that's over now let's get to
that transmission
so who's where it was this the [ __ ] how
the [ __ ] used it as a field hospital
acts report is from way before the car
seriously like kings of Wizards days
Wizards
let's see what this does
what the hell
Jadey
[Music]
what's a healthy tablet
hey truck like of them
yeah
okay that's all of them I do not like
those guys they just crawl out of an
emergency no I don't think so it's like
some kind of nest sweet
come on through that floor
right there's even more fluffy
across the way around
it's about time we got the hell out of
here hey talk about what happened back
[Music]